well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
in the next half hour or so then we will
see what's making the headlines with
the political editors from two national
newspapers uh pippa crea from the daily
mirror and harry cole
from the sun great to see both of you on
a you know a very reflective day as
we'll see from the front pages
um so let's start with the metro shall
we focusing on the queen's words marking
the one year anniversary
of the first coved lockdown in the uk
front page of the daily mail boris
johnson also marks that milestone saying
the pandemic will haunt him for the rest
of his life
the prime minister is quoted on the
front of the yorkshire post saying it's
been
a year like no other while the times
leads on the tributes to those who have
died
during the pandemic the guardian reports
on boris johnson's regrets
over the past year but refused to commit
to a public inquiry
into the government's decisions the
daily mirror says it's time
to learn from the mistakes and urges the
prime minister
to set a date for an inquiry
summer holidays at home again that's the
headline in the eye
as foreign trips are banned the sun
leading on prince harry's
new job as he takes up a post at a
mental health company in california
and the ft reports that fraud at german
payments company wirecard
started more than a decade before it
collapsed
into insolvency in 2019
so pippa harry with their thoughts and
choices um where do you start with a day
like today
so much has happened to so many people
and perhaps
fittingly pippa many have started with
the with the loss with the lives
lost and lives irrevocably changed
if i can say it yes
and i think that for everybody that has
been watching events unfold over the
last year
and seen how the nhs has had to cope
with the
pandemic and how the government has made
decisions some of which
many people feel it didn't make quick
enough ultimately today
it feels like is the right time to think
about there's 126 000 people
who have died of their families
of people whose lives have been touched
by coronavirus possibly suffering from
long covered themselves
and you know everybody in the country
has been affected in some way or another
whether it's having to cope with the
restrictions on their lives
um all the way through to losing loved
ones and it really felt today
that um it was right to strike a sombra
tone and
people were lighting candles as front
page of the times their shows
um right across the country and having
and marking the
the moment um in in very different and
often very personal ways as well
i just remember sitting there watching
the prime minister's press conference a
year ago
today and thinking how astonishing it
was that he was about to impose a
national lock down
never for a minute did i or no don't
many of my fellow citizens think that we
would be
in the same position a year on and i
don't think any of us can really
have understood at that point the full
scale of the pandemic
and the damage that it would inflict
certainly looking back now
um it's it really seems quite
astonishing that so much has happened
and we've had such a bleak year
but today as most of the front page
papers have uh
front pages have decided to mark in some
way um the memorial really the
anniversary of that first lockdown and
all the lives that have been lost
and yet even on that date the 23rd of
march 2020 many people thought it was
already too late
and the number who died that day was
already extraordinary
and daily mail chooses to focus on the
prime minister visibly shattered they
say the prime minister's pained
confession
on the night the nation mourned covert
catastrophe this will haunt me for as
long as i live
and i'm sure it will there's so much to
dwell on but also for him
very soon after this he was ill and you
know then not long after that he was in
hospital desperately ill wasn't he harry
yeah you sort of uh it's one of those
days where you stop and and take stock
actually i found it quite
a strange day today actually just
writing um
some of the things we sort of did a big
wrap of everything we had the the queen
the prime minister you know hundreds of
people standing outside
um outside hospitals police cars
stopping traffic you know
it felt to me like almost like it
happened organically this sort of um
you know some of the some of the things
that the scenes we saw looked today a
little bit like remembrance sunday
and you think that's something that sort
of became a you know became a
organically became at the day of
memorial on that day and it looks like
that
you know i suspect this is going to
happen every day this year for at least
a few years i think the prime minister
name pointed out that you know this will
it i don't think he actually said the
word haunt although it's in that in that
headline
he didn't say look this will this will
be with us for a very long time and he
wasn't just speaking personally i think
he was
speaking slightly more broadly for for
everyone
and the 23rd of march seems just become
this this
focal point because it was such an
unusual day
it was such an unusual week that um back
in uh back back last year
that i think everyone seems to have
slightly just stopped and taken stock
and the usual
blows and trading of and political horse
trading seems to have stopped the day
today
i'll be really interested to see what
happens at pmq's tomorrow whether that
mood continues and there's a bit more of
a
sort of collegiate atmosphere in the
house of commons or whether it's going
to be a bit like memorial sunday
remember it's sunday story where you
know everyone stops pauses where's their
poppy
looks at that day and then carries on
with their lives i think it might take a
little bit longer to get back to normal
um given how fresh everything is yes and
we're still in it
uh we're still in lockdown um no doubt
people are looking forward to seeing
family members next monday which is
you know the next stage of of the
lockdown lifting
um and then we talked they talked often
about surges again didn't they
this wall of vaccinated people the
fortifications of
of the vaccines program um whether that
will slow any future surges
um but on to the guardian johnson admits
covert regrets
rejects the clamor for a public inquiry
for the moment
what did you think about the reasons
they all gave about
this the stuff they wish they'd known
and for bros johnson it was the lack of
understanding about asymptomatic cases
uh we heard them say they wish they'd
have the data they can really track the
pandemic
carefully now but but even across europe
they had no real idea where it was or
what it was doing
and the importation of cases as well
from abroad italy
france spain the three countries which
mainly delivered the cases to the uk at
that point
did you accept all of those pippa do you
think as as good reasons for
errors made i think people do understand
that this was an unprecedented situation
and the governments across the world
were really
facing some terribly difficult decisions
set against the background of many many
unknowns and of course there were things
on the scientific
side like for example the fact that uh
the virus can be transmitted
asymptomatically which
would have helped had they known at the
time but there were decisions made then
which could have been made differently
not least um the time it took the
government to follow the scientific
advice which boris johnson likes to cite
so regularly
and actually implement lockdown now even
if you could give the government the
benefit of the diet and say look
come on this was a really really tough
situation no politicians had to face
something like this before
and say look the first lockdown happened
and it was devastating
um that so many lives were lost but it
was really uncharted territory
can you still apply that logic to the
second lockdown
the second time that boris johnson was
advised by scientists to shut down the
economy and to get children out of
schools in order to prevent
a further surge in in uh in case numbers
and he resisted it
for quite a long time and in fact we all
ended up partly because of the
pressure brought to bear by the treasury
and rishi sinak of only having a four
week lockdown which effectively was a
circuit
breaker and i don't know whether it
really had that much impact on case
numbers
then we saw the second the second wave
and of course
you know more than half of the deaths
that have taken place have taken place
since november and um you know how many
of those might have been preventable if
different decisions were made so well i
think that there will be will
there will be a public understanding
there is public understanding that in
the early days of the pandemic it was
really uncharted territory and terribly
difficult for anyone
then early lessons weren't learned when
it came to
making similar decisions later on and i
think that's why there's this camera for
public inquiry
sooner rather than later because rather
than saying okay let's look at this in
two years time
when there's no cases left at all you
look at look at some of the lessons that
should be learnt now that actually could
end up saving lives
as we go forward through the rest of
this year potentially with the third
week coming in from
from the from europe yes the mirror
asking that same question as well
um the idea of lessons needing to be
learned
um time to learn from the mistakes they
say there
and there's certainly some big decisions
coming if we look at the eye harry
namely for many people about foreign
travel not just holidays
visiting relatives who may live abroad
whatever reason you need to travel there
are many
there will be some really big decisions
next month weren't there about what they
do about this
yeah i think that sort of alarm bells
went for anyone hoping for a quick
getaway uh
or a quick re uh um quick leaving this
country
um without having to go through a huge
amount of quarantine and process and
paperwork and
valid reasons and the like will be
slightly unnerved by the fact that boris
johnson has said tonight
at the press conference that he will be
announcing the review on april the 5th
um we were all expecting it to be a
little bit later than that april the
12th with a view to
perhaps it coming in in may and these
changes the fact is bringing it forward
makes me think um that it's not
particularly good news for travellers
um certainly to europe there's a sort of
painfully denied but
nonetheless growing speculation that
france may have to go
uh into onto the red list which means
that visitors will have to
um not only quarantine for 10 days but
do so in a hotel at their own
at their own uh at their own cost um
look
you just have to look at the numbers in
europe you have to look at the reaction
of the european union you have to look
at the reaction of european leaders
this is not a continent that's going in
the right way and
as the pm and chris whittier have been
at payne's to
excuse me it pains to point out
what happens in europe excuse me you
have to shout it's not covered when you
cough don't you
it's not a symptom i was working very
late and i
ran in just before i came on air and ate
some peanuts and then
i'm suffering as chris whitty has been
at pains to point out what happens in
europe tends to happen
you know all the way through this
pandemic three weeks later in britain
now
you could argue that we've already had
our second third wave whatever you will
call it and this is the europe catching
up with the kent variant and
all sorts of matters at play but things
are very worried and you know
i think that matt hancock in particular
has been very keen to push this idea of
britain
open internally free to move around
uh in the country pubs restaurants
reopened but borders closed
and i feel like the debate is going that
way towards matt hancock's vision i
could talk about that all night to be
fair but we are
running out of time but we will see you
in a few moments after this break
we will come back with working 9-5
prince harry takes up a new job
more on that after the break
[Music]
journalism is under attack it's clearly
marked as press
the right has actually been declared you
have to have the facts
i will stand in the way of the enemy you
have to have key evidence on camera
because people are doubting everything
you are further pushing the agenda that
is condemning all of us to prove
wrong to expose corruption
to show the truth i just want to
celebrate i don't think any journalist
wants anything more than that
[Music]
i'm adam parsons i'm skies europe
correspondent based here in brussels
more flares going off a volley of rocks
bubbles have been pulled up out and are
being used as missiles of hell
at these police
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place
for news we have now
left italy and entered france nobody's
asked to check our identity
[Music]
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr bonio
why not meeting you fishing does have
the potential
to stymie an enormous economic deal
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing
but the speed at which those changes are
happening
it's devastating actually
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now the political
editors from two national papers pippa
crea from the mirror
harry cole from the sun welcome back to
both of you your story
in the sun tell us more this is pretty
patel harry
yeah so um never one to shy away from a
fight i think pretty patel tomorrow will
cross the road and
uh and start multiple fights fresh on
the back of her policing bill
climbed down we have something in the in
the pipeline called the sovereign
borders bill
which is going to be spicy to uh to say
the least in it
um she is looking at new ways to stop uh
illegal immigrants crossing the channel
in small boats um
she is starting a fairly controversial
and punchy fight with
with the legal establishment over their
um use of uh
sort of court time on hopeless appeals
for for migrants and she's not shying
away from the fight
we've interviewed her in the paper
tomorrow and she's laying the groundwork
for what should be a fairly and sundry
intervention tomorrow and um
i have to say um she seems to be
slightly reveling in it
um this is all in the in the sort of
tory manifesto she feels that this is
what the
the the government have been elected to
do she thinks she's got the public on
her side
um but um if my twitter mentions over
the last
you know a few days sort of teeing some
of this stuff up anything to go by
and there's gonna be lots of screaming
from uh from the commentariat
yeah we will look out for that
announcement uh obviously um front page
of the sun though a sun employment issue
or special um the job description for
prince harry's new role pippa
yes so prince harry has sort of stuck to
his word and got a job
um and uh you know it's going to be be
supporting himself and his family from
now on
um and he's going to become chief impact
officer
at a us coaching and mental health firm
and the wall street journal broke this
story
earlier in the day and it's i mean it's
it's very la isn't it i mean it
very much fits with his new la lifestyle
i mean does anyone know
here what chief impact officer is
certainly in the corporate world i
believe it's actually quite rare
and you're more likely to find somebody
with that title in
in for example charity something like
amnesty international or something
um but it does very much fit with sort
of you know the the the sort of
la i think they're san francisco aren't
they
californian lifestyle and he's going to
be putting he's going to be getting
involved in
um product strategy decisions in the
charity side of
of the firm and he's going to be a
public advocate really on
topics including mental health which is
as we all know there's some huge amount
of of advocacy on anyway so you know i
mean
there's a there's a sort of school of
thought that he just needs to turn up
until he'll be doing his job but uh
certainly there's lots of watching to
see how he's getting on indeed so
self optimization i can barely say it
let alone know what it is but uh
you know there are mixed views on this
are they not um
harry you've got sort of five seconds to
give me your overall
well the poor boy was apparently cut off
financially so
um it's good to see him play up his
bootstraps and uh and getting uh getting
an honest day's work but uh
it does sound a little bit like a load
of la tech
woke mumbo jumbo to me we'll see it half
eleven thank you both
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage
[Applause]
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free
[Music]
so
so
you